بنكييف ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد البابا
اهلا بك معنا في هذه النشره محمد اذا هل
بالفعل روسيا تستعد لمحاوله اخذ او
السيطره على كيف يعني هل هناك استعدادات
معينه من قبل اوكرانيا لذلك
من وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه عن احتمال ان
تكون روسيا بهجوم عند وبعد في الشهر الاول
من العام المقبل اي يعني خلال ثلاثه او
اربعه اسابيع قد يعني من الاحتمالات ان
تكون روسيا بهجوم على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف ذلك بدات هناك استعدادات عسكريه في
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه واعاده انتشار
لقوات الطيور ابونا او الدفاع الشعبي
اضافه الى قوات من الحرس الوطني في محيط
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف يعني بالتعامل مع
انتشار على الحدود بلا روسيه الاوكرانيا
من الجهه الشماليه شمال العاصمه الاوكيه
في شمال المقاطعه وايضا في مقاطعه
هناك ايضا يعني همم عمليات او خطوط دفاعيه
بدات تبنى من الجيش الاوكراني ولا ننسى ان
اوكرانيا بدات بتشهيد حائط طويل على طول
الحدود الشماليه مع بيلاروسيا وهذا من
الاستعدادات والاحتياطات التي
انفذه وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه خوفا من اي
هجوم عسكري قد يطال العاصمه الاوكرانيه كم
او حتى قد يطال مدن في غرب اوكرانيا مثل
مقاطعه فولين ومقاطعهما
هل الضربات همم الروسيه على البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه تؤثر ربما على همم
الامدادات العسكريه على الارض في اوكرانيا
هل تؤثر على جودتها
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه منذ بدايه الحرب حتى
الان هناك تطور تصاعدي في يعني طبيعه عمل
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في النقل
العتاد خاصه يعني في بدايه الحرب عندما
بدات تصل المساعدات العسكريه من الدول
الغربيه كان هناك محاولات من روسيا لضرب
خطوط الامداد ولكنها لم تحصل على لم
تستطيع مواقف خطوط الامداد العسكريه حتى
هذه يعني حتى هذه الاسماء اي سلاح يقدم
الى اوكرانيا يستطيع خلال 24 ساعه من
دخوله الى اراضي الاوكرانيه ان يكون في
خطوط همم يعني الخطوط التماس في شرقي
اوكرانيا وهي مسافات تبعد حوالي 1,000 كم
لذلك هناك ديناميكيه جيده من الجانب
الاوكراني وياخذ وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
بتاخذ بعين الاعتبار انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي وهمم خاصه عن شبكه همم سكك
الحديد لذلك تم تعويض بعض همم يعني اعاده
همم بعض همم القطارات التي تعمل على
الديوس او حتى الفحم الحجري وذلك عن نقص
في يعني سكك الح دي التي تعمل على الكره
محمد علي هناك عاجل على الشاشه امامنا
يتحدث بان الشركه المشغله لشبكه الكهرباء
الاوكرانيه تقول بان اصلاح الاعطال
سيستغرق وقتا اطول هذه المره بتالي كيف
سيؤثر ذلك على الحياه بشكل عام على الاداء
او اداء الجيش على الارض والميدان في
اوكرانيا
العسكريه يختلف عن تجويد الطاقه
الكهربائيه
للجيش الاوكراني ياخذها بعين الاعتبار
لانه هناك امن اوكرانيا في الدرجه الاولى
ولكن ما يعني ما اعلن اليوم من قبل حوالي
دقائق من الان من وزاره الطاقه والشبكه
شركه الكهرباء الاوكرانيه ان الاعطال التي
يعني بسبب باستمرار الضربات على محطات
الطاقه ستؤثر المدن الاوكرانيه والشعبراني
بشكل كبير من انقطاع كبير لسياره كهربائي
ويعني بدانا الان
عن يعني تشغيل او بدا حاله الطوارئ في
تثبيت الشبكه سياره كهربائيه وتيار
كهربائي كافه المدن الاوكرانيه
التي تتحدث عنها محمد
اي مدى هي كافيه
حاله الطوارئ هي يعني قطع تيار كهربائي
بين اثني عشر ساعه الى 16 ساعه اي ربما
ستكون يعني فقط بفتره تزويد الطاقه
الكهربائيه انها تتجاوز الثمانيه ساعات في
يعني في اليوم الكامل وهذه الفتره قليله
خاصه ان انظمه التدفئه المركزيه الخاصه
تعمل فقط عبر التيار الكهربائي مما يعني
ان يعني سيعاني المواطنون والذين يعانون
من قطاع الطويل التيار الكهربائي من حاله
برد كبيره في المنازل وخارج المنازل خاصه
انا الدرجات الحراره وكما ترون خلف يعني
تتساقط في اوكرانيا منذ يومين درجات
الحراره تتدنى الى ما دون اثنين او ثلاثه
درجات
وهناك يعني الارصاد الجويه درجات الحراره
تتدنى خلال اسبوع
وانما ايضا على المرابطين على خطوط التماس
من الجيش الاوكراني كذلك
نعم بالفعل هناك تاثر كبير ولكن كما قلت
يعني الجيش الاوكراني يعتماما خاصه مثلا
في مناطق الشرق اوكراني او خطوط التماس
والكهرباء لا تعمل بشكل منذ ثلاثه او
اربعه اشهر لا وجود للتيار الكهربائي هناك
يعني يمكن القول ان معظم الجنود يتدفون
علل عبر الحطب يعني يستخدمونه وسائل
تقليديه قديمه في التدفئه وفي يعني
التبادل بين الوحدات والاخرى ولكن الجيش
الاوكراني كما قلت يعني تماما هذه المخاطر
واستعد لهذه المخاطر قبل ثلاثه او اربع
اشهر خاصه ان القوات الاوكرانيه التي تخوض
قتال عنيف جدا وشرس الدفاع عن مدينه الجيش
الروسي يحاول بكل ثقه
يعني بفعل هذه الدرجات التي يعني اليوم
كانت وخلال الاسبوع الماضي وحتى المسيرات
التي تطلق وذلك لضرب خطوط الامداد
اللوجستيه للجيش الاوكراني ولكن ما نراه
على ارض الواقع حتى هذه لحظه الخطه
الاوكرانيه في الصمود يمكن الى حد ما تعمل
بشكل كبير هناك ضغط كبير على القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه في شرق اوكرانيا في
جنوب اوكرانيا وحتى في شمال افريقيا
استعدادات للجيش الاوكراني منذ عده اشهر
لهذه الحاله من نقص الكهرباء والجمود
والبرد ما هي هذه الاستعدادات تحديدا
سريعا لو سمحت
يعني معدات للتدفئه التقليديه
وايضا لاجهزه الاتصالات
لبطاريات
وسائل الاتصال
التيار الكهربائي منذ شهر مارس حتى الان
بذلك في تلك المناطق يعيش الاوكراني واصبح
معتادا على طبيعه
[موسيقى]